>> Alright, so I'm just going to drag these down. Let's see. Where
do I want to drag them to, down to Band Detail I guess.
>> Yeah, but not above the name.
>> Oh, not above the name. Right. And I'll do that for all of them.
>> Yup. And so you have columns so you
can drag those fields to the other side also.
>> Okay. All right, cool. So I'll put my contact information
on the right column. I'll put this other stuff over here.
>> And if you wanted to,
at the top here, it says you can drag sections. So you can
even create new headers for more information, like if we had a finite
set of stuff that was only about the stage, we could possibly drag
down a section and name it like stage information or something like that.
>> Cool. Okay, so that wasn't so bad. I
just had to drag all these fields on. I think
I still prefer using the Wizard, though, because I like
that it does everything for me. Schema Builder's cool, though.
>> I mean,
there are tradeoffs to both. Definitely with
the Wizard it allows you to, you know,
do everything you might want to do from security
to field creation in one clean sweep. But
if we would say, knew our entire data
model, right from the beginning, it would probably
be pretty tedious to have to go through
the seven steps for let's say, 100 fields.
>> Right,
[INAUDIBLE].
>> But dragging them all, you know, in the Schema Builder
it allows you do to a lot at once really quickly.
>> Okay, makes sense.